頑
[拍手]
今日の体育は特別師を呼んでるぞ。
誰だろう?
大谷に翔平選手だ。
[拍手]
大谷翔平さん、野球で大切なことは何でしょう?
うん。ま、気合いと根性、
気合いと根性で今日もキャッチボールから始めるぞ。
お、
[音楽]
こいつはターゲットの大谷に消兵。うん。ま、生物的弱者。一撃で終わらせるね。
ふ、ボールが1
つは限らないぞ。二刀流だと。
うん。ま、浅めしま
ならばできた。
これでどうだ?
こうなったら接近戦だ。
うわ。
[音楽]
憧れるのやめましょう。あ、そろそろ時間だ。
確かにお前は野球が甘い。だからお前が何
でも打ち返すことを逆に利用したのさ。
お前の打ち返した弾が近くの火力発電所に
当たるようにああかじめ起動調整した。
そしてこの黒い玉は半径100kmの炎を
吸収する。
誰がお前に憧れるか。くらえ。屋根す。
うん。ま、無理ゲ。
[音楽]
お前は太陽に焦がれるのさ。あ、
報酬のうまい棒だ。
うーん。
次のターゲットはこいつだ。かし、ガかし、ガかし。
中貧乏人の味方なよ。
[音楽]
いらっしゃい。長しの試食する。
食べるよ。食べれよ。
ああ。シスシルーパースプラオ。
[音楽]
こいつはターゲットの駄菓しバ
じがりこ食べるかい?
[音楽]
うわあ。
綿菓し防弾直器だと。
冗談冗談。
ここにある駄菓しなもで食べていいわよ。
む、無料。うん。うん。あ、ああ。ああ。あ、
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああ。
うん。おお、
めっちゃデブすけ。
[音楽]
お腹いっぱいで動けないよ。
シめしめ。これでとめよ。あ、
トンがコメリカリック。やー。
俺がただお菓子を食べただけだと思うなよ。
パチパチパニックを大量に食べたデブスは
[拍手]
体に電気をまとっていた。
抜きさらにデブけは
[音楽]
ラムネのB玉も腹に蓄えていた。
何このおもちゃ?面白そうだな。や、やめろ。スーパー。
[音楽]
う。
だしもたくさん食べて勝負にも買って満足。満足。もうマイ棒持ってんならこれでいいよな。
[音楽]
はあ。
次のターゲットはこいつら。
[音楽]
この度なんポッけすることになりました。
ん、なんだこれ?
バンチャラジオップアップ2025
渋谷で改善することになりました。
イエー。
参加費はなんと無料です。
グッズの購入得典で写真撮影もできます。グッズのラインナップはこちら。イベント限定のく事も用意してあるのでお楽しみに。
[音楽]
概要欄、コメント欄のURL、はの
QRコードからしてね。
詳しくは概要欄、またコメント欄の
URLから。
へえ、面白そうだな。
うん。
ニュースです。日本の国報
万カラットの巨大ダイヤが豪邸から盗まれました。ほ、
クリスマスのシーズン以外は暇すぎて泥棒をしてるってわけか。ターゲットの泥棒サンタ。まずか今年もめお侵入しよそうな煙突けた。
かかったな。ようこそお正期部屋へ。この
[音楽]
万ボルトの流れる武器試してみたかったんだよね。俺ら子供の夢を壊すんだは許さないぞ。ま、待ってくれ。
スイッチ2を開けるか。スイッチ
[音楽]
2。
ああ。
メリークリスマス。ほ。君のスイッチももらってあげよ。
あの髭デブサンタ絶逃さねえ。た
さてち俺の暗え。クリスマ。あ、まずは中にの動きを止めないと。そうだ。
[音楽]
どうせ6に飯も与えられてねえんだろ。
ついてこい。ついてこい。
そろそろじゃねえよ。
[拍手]
[音楽]
もう逃さないぜ。こうなったの最終手段だ。ヘビークリスタル。
[拍手]
バニア。ああ。
クリスマスは今年はよてこない。
[音楽]
一見落得だよ。
お
な。なんで俺の居場所がバカ。
俺は自分のスイッチに基情報を特定できる
GPSをつけてるんだ。
メニーブリスラッシュ。そんでもって俺はお姉さんレディフリムカスな坊や。
[音楽]
バウバケモだ。また
欧州のうまい棒だ。
最後のターゲットはこいつら。なんだこの匂い?あれはターゲットの便次郎。お前が便次郎か。
[音楽]
まか。また俺に嫌がらしに来たやつか。
お前の存在は他人に迷惑をかけてる。
どいつもこいつも俺のことを晴れ物扱いしやがって。全の呼吸いの方ゲリラゴ賛成だ。
血の国いつのかだ。鉄陣
君賢いね。
血の悟空2の方対雷戦うあ
便の呼吸の方便風外
お前こそなかなかやるな
もう終わりにしようか全集中の呼吸銃の方戦部
[拍手]
死の呼吸10のた、流一戦。
うわー。え、
素晴らしい提案をしよう。お前も綺麗にならないか。な
んでみんな僕を遠ざけるんだ?
お前が臭いからだよ。
ひどい。
うわあ。
く、臭すぎる。
[音楽]
うわあ。
なんてな。君9の方透明爆卓俺は逃げてる
間にも罠を張っていたのさ。
先集中
たの仮フェイパー。
[音楽]
これでおしまいだ。
え、ただ臭いってだけで物扱いは良くなかったよ。ごめんな。
ありがとう。ありがとう。
[音楽]
これからは友達だ。
やっぱりくせえ。
なんでだよ。
どれが面白かったかコメントしてね。